alright now I'm going to use this second
law here and I'm gonna kind of leapfrog
offer and give you an interesting
example right see here I've to the 5 + 2
squared
well the secondary example - what is the
powers we're also the same to the 5
there's loads of ways you can think
about this we're gonna do more than one
but I just want you to think about it
through the lens of this index shortcut
first okay the bases are the same and
I'm dividing right
so therefore the power B will are -
Widow I'll subtract okay so I should
have five minus five which of course is
okay but hold on a second hold on hold
on hold on ways that me I'll get you a
question who sent you right now this is
a little bit weird because it doesn't
quite fit with what we defined powers to
be in the first place right powers are
like multiply repeatedly right do it
three times or four times or five its
cetera what does it mean to multiply no
times we could take that first okay why
did you tell us the answer then we'll
explore explore together all right so so
this is one okay a hundred a second let
me just say that and make sure you have
this all clear
- that has zero when you multiply by two
how many times no times right you end up
with one right now there's a couple of
ways to see this number one we just
looked at the index law right so that's
what we got right but just like I went
from here to here I'm gonna do the
equivalent wine again right down here
okay so I'm I'm too terrified that's
gonna be my numerator there are five of
these to 0 okay you riding this with me
five - but I've also got five twos on
the denominator right in fact they're in
the exact same thing if you divide
something by itself of course you'll get
one right 3/3 5/5
rockmelon / rockmelon you get one every
time right
everything will cancel and you're just
left with one okay you go probably see
right these examples I've been using -
as the base every single time okay just
cuz I like powder - but I could have
chosen a different base right like
suppose suppose I just changed these
into threes right if I change this into
threes what happens on the right-hand
side here that now I change into a three
as well but apart from that everything
is the same it's still gonna be five
threes on the top five deuce on the
bottom that'll still all cancel and
you'll still get one okay so now we're
starting to see if you race the suit of
this power or three to this power or
anything to this power you keep ending
up on one question okay all right we'll
get to that in a second so you're glad
you mentioned that
let's just take this idea first though
what we got from - and let's put it into
a wall cuz wanna do this every single
time did it tiresome and you get the
same answer every time so how would I
phrase that over here in general terms
if I have a number any number you like
right and I raise it to the power of
zero every single time you're gonna get
one okay now let me just convince you of
this in another way because it's always
great to see problems from more than one
angle okay
just next to where you're doing all of
this I'd like you to drop a small table
with me okay just a small table just do
a quick one don't worry about doing it
with a ruler because I just I'd rather
have it there quickly rather than we can
make the point pretty easily and I'd
like you to put eight rows two columns
eight rows one of those two three and
I've got two columns okay
I'm just going to illustrate something
really quickly okay excuse me
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna compare a
number and I'm gonna call the number n
infan umber with what happens when I
raise 2 to that power 2 to the power of
n let's see I really like to okay so for
reasons that will become clear in a
second I'm going to leave a few rows
blank I'm gonna leave 1 2 3 4 rows back
I'm just gonna start here 1 2 you'll see
why in a minute or two right so if n is
equal to 1 right then here I'll have 2
to the power of 1 which of course is 2
I just got a single to my next row if I
have 2 square right which of course is
for grades absolutely and I can keep my
patentee going okay if I had more rows I
could go 16 32 64 etc okay now we were
building this going downwards right but
can you see just this is a pattern going
downwards there is just as much a
pattern going upwards right you see how
if I go from here to here I double and
then he leafy I double right so if I win
in Reverse if I went in Reverse I would
be harming good night from 8 to 4 I
multiply by 1/2 and then from 4 to 2 I
multiply by a hub okay follow the
pattern with me right 3 2 1 0
so this should be 2 power 0 and I just
keep on having 1/2 of 2
here's one just like we saw before
ok now I've left off these three rows
deliberately will come to them in a
minute but I wonder what you think would
go they don't then shout it out or what
should I have a think okay I'll leave
them like for the row we'll come back to
okay so a the power 0 equals 1 okay but
a question they got raised with 4 was
well I switch this around a little bit
what if instead of easy
in the index what if we have it as the
base right 0 ^ something well excuse me
if please zero squared
for instance zero squared by definition
that's zero time zero which last I
checked to zero right okay so I could be
zero cubed with that zero times zero
times zero which last I checked this
stills here now this is interesting
right we saw here if you raise any
number to the power of zero you'll get
one so just sprays you slightly
differently if you take zero and raise
it to any power you like you'll always
end up with zero okay so this is our
fourth index law okay whatever you see
doesn't matter if it's zero to the power
of a million you're like being them a
better write out on beer insurance just
to be sure
no don't this shortcut you saving okay